Alright guys, so this is example number two. So the thing is there is not a fixed way to
use quarterly theory. It works with every strategy. You can say it is a tool to confirm
your entries. Typically, the prime entry that you would get is during the manipulation phase
because that is when price is going into some form of PD array to either sweep sell
site liquidity, buy site liquidity, or it will go into a PD array. So I want to give
you an example here. So if I go to the four hour time premiere, now this is going to be
how I use this with the auto flow trading strategy. So over here, you can see we are clearly
sorry for that. Okay, so you can clearly said, see that we are bullish here. Now, you can see
we have this auto block here, this auto block right here. Focus on that. I will mark this
out like that. Now let's go to 15 minute time frame. Now if I go to 15 minutes time frame,
you can see over here, we came into the auto block. So if I disable this just to be just to make
the chart clean, this was the four hour auto block price tapped into it. And we had a shift in
market structure. Now notice, when did price come into the PD array? And when did price take out
this this low here? First off, the big quarter was the manipulation quarter. During this phase,
the manipulation quadrant of the manipulation quarter, you can see we also took out this
liquidity and this liquidity. But you can see during the manipulation quarter, we tapped into the
auto block. Now afterwards, what do we have? We have a shift in the market structure right here.
Now the green box is the expansion quarter. And over here, you can see we have a beautiful
auto block here. And once price came into our auto block, and you can see that during the
manipulation phase of the distribution quarter. So this green box is the expansion quarter. Okay.
But look at the manipulation quadrant, the red box here. This box went into this auto block.
So do you understand what I'm trying to teach here? If you can understand this,
this will significantly improve the way you trade. All right.
Look at this carefully. We marked out the four hour auto block during the manipulation phase
during the manipulation quarter. We went into the higher time frame PD array. Now afterwards,
we have a shift in the market structure. Now we had a lower time frame auto block. And during
the expansion quarter, we had a manipulative quadrant. And that pushed the price into this
auto block for expansion. So we also had this break a block, you can say price taps into here,
and it pushed back up. So by now, you must get the idea what I'm trying to teach you. We use the
quarterly theory to improve our win rate. And when we are using this with other strategies,
we want to make sure that we are taking our entries at the right time. All right. Are we
taking our entry during the manipulation phase? Or are we taking our entry during the expansion
phase? We primarily want to take our entry on the lower time frame during the expansion phase.
And we want to see price go into our PD high time frame PD array during the manipulation phase.
I hope that clears it. I'll just move on to another example.